-Our next guest --
"So Happy It Hurts Tour"
kicks off on June 6th
in Baltimore.
Performing the Grammy-nominated
title track to his album,
"So Happy It Hurts",
please welcome Bryan Adams!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey! Whoo!
♪♪
-♪ Whoa-oa-oa ♪
♪ Whoa-oa-oa ♪
♪ Whoa-oa-oa-oa-oa ♪
-♪ Driving down
Trans-Canada One ♪
♪ Top down, I got the radio on,
alright ♪
♪ Gonna get there tonight ♪
♪♪
♪ A little closer,
every bend in the road ♪
♪ Motor runnin', think I'm gonna
explode, alright ♪
♪ I got you in my sights ♪
♪♪
♪ Blacktop burnin'
underneath my wheels ♪
♪ It's crazy how I feel ♪
♪ I'm so happy it hurts ♪
♪ I'm so glad it's outrageous ♪
♪♪
♪ That stupid grin on my face ♪
♪ Must be some kind of curse ♪
♪ You put a spell on me, baby ♪
♪ I'm so happy it hurts ♪
-♪ Whoa-oa-oa ♪
♪ Whoa-oa-oa ♪
-♪ Sun is shinin',
there ain't no more rain ♪
♪ Step on the gas and forget
all the pain, let it go ♪
♪ Out on the open road ♪
♪♪
♪ Rocky mountains
in the rearview mirror ♪
♪ I can't wait till I get there,
alright ♪
♪ I'm gonna drive all night ♪
♪♪
♪ Been around the world,
there ain't much I've missed ♪
♪ But I ain't felt
nothin' like this ♪
♪ I'm so happy it hurts ♪
♪ I'm so glad it's outrageous ♪
♪ That stupid grin on my face ♪
♪ Must be some kind of curse ♪
♪ You put a spell on me, baby ♪
-♪ Whoa-oa-oa ♪
-♪ I'm so happy it hurts ♪
♪ Whoa-oa-oa ♪
♪♪
♪ Whoa-oa-oa-oa-oa ♪
-♪ I'm so happy it hurts ♪
Come on!
♪ I'm so happy it hurts ♪
♪ I'm so glad it's outrageous ♪
♪ You know, I think
it's contagious ♪
♪ That stupid grin on my face ♪
-♪ Whoa-oa-oa ♪
-♪ Must be some kind of curse ♪
-♪ You put a spell on me, baby ♪
-♪ Whoa-oa-oa ♪
-♪ I'm so happy it hurts ♪
♪ Whoa-oa-oa-oa-oa ♪
-Hey!
-Come on now.